buenas noches para usted le pido un
breve contexto sobre Cuáles son las
principales discrepancias entre
demócratas y republicanos que impiden
alcanzar un acuerdo
bueno primero que todo muchas gracias
por invitarme Esta es una crisis por
primera vez en la historia
norteamericana en donde el poder
ejecutivo
está divorciando del poder legislativo y
es una crisis muy parecida Parece
Mentira a lo que está pasando en un
pequeño país amigo nuestro que se llama
Ecuador en Estados Unidos la
Constitución no permite disolver el
congreso pero cuando el presidente
desacata el congreso como va a suceder
Aparentemente ya sin si no hay acuerdo y
creo que no va a haber acuerdo y el
presidente Joe biden decide de zacatal
congreso y seguir pagando porque eso lo
va a suceder el presidente no va a
suspender el pago de la deuda y se va a
cerrar a la enmienda catorceava
toca tangencialmente el problema porque
claramente lo que está escrito en las
enmiendas se refiere a las deudas de los
estados que perdieron la guerra de la
guerra civil norteamericana en 1860 y
ocho fue pasar aprobadas enmienda pero
la guerra terminó por supuesto en 1865
Entonces qué sucede el presidente biden
decide desacatar el congreso bueno que
el congreso tendría la excusa para hacer
un impeachment después lo que hicieron a
Donald Trump dos veces
el congreso no ha tenido una excusa para
hacer el de hasta ahora pero la pudiera
obtener si él desacata El Congreso sobre
el techo de la deuda lo cual por
supuesto llegaría a un juicio en el
senado que moriría ahí después de un
gran circo de varios meses sí Federico
le pido un poco de detalles sobre esta
enmienda 14 a la que usted hace
referencia que podría utilizar Joe biden
para salir de esta situación de bloqueo
financiero concretamente de qué se trata
y cuáles son los pros y los contras de
usarla
bueno nunca se ha usado en este contexto
Y ese es el problema es una
interpretación jurídica novedosa la
enmienda dice que las deudas legalmente
adquiridas no pueden ser rechazadas o no
puede evitarse pagar pero se refería
esta enmienda a las deudas del gobierno
norteamericano que incurrieron que
incurrió para derrotar a los alzados de
la federación desde el sur Entonces es
aplicable o no es muy difícil de lograr
pensar qué va a decidir la Corte Suprema
que además es trompista probablemente
dirán que no tiene nada que ver entonces
el presidente está entre la espada y la
pared y desacata el congreso
entra a un proceso de impeachment Y por
supuesto no va a lograr nada en el
senado Pero sería el circo mayor del
último año de
Y qué pasaría bueno el presidente puede
simplemente seguir pagando las deudas y
dejar de pagar Los sueldos de la
administración para lograr una respuesta
negativa hacia los republicanos Pero eso
llevaría a una cantidad de demandas
jurídicas terribles que no podemos
imaginar en este momento el tamaño de la
complejidad o las las consecuencias para
la sociedad norteamericana lo que yo
quiero decirle a los que tienen deuda de
los Estados Unidos en nuestro país a los
bancos centrales a los bancos privados
es que los Estados Unidos vamos a seguir
pagando la deuda pase lo que pase